Madfinger Games is
game developers,
and we are creating
amazing games which
are running on
multiple platforms.
That means on iOS,
Android, and Facebook.
My role as a
marketing director is
to show off the world that
we are creating the games.
This means bringing new users,
new players to our game,
and also to care about our
huge community of players which
are already playing our
game, and to give them
interesting content to
bring them back to the game
again and again.
Community is something like the
biggest or strongest marketing
tool for us because they
can share their activities
on our game, and they can
bring also new users for us.
They can share the
score with friends.
And the community and number of
players are increasing by them.